- Last time you were here,
we didn't get to talk about
like how you were a singer, like as well.
- So
- Oh dear god.
- How long have you been singing?
- I, I look I'm, I'm
nowhere near as disciplined
and talented as you are.
- [Kelly] Not true.
- Uh, but I was in show
choir in high school.
- Me too!
- Yeah!
(audience cheers)
- Yes!
- I wore all the sequined outfits.
- Oh my God, we had red and black vests,
white shirts, red bow ties.
- Were red and black, those
were our school colors.
- Did we ever compete against each other?
- I don't know, but if we did, we won.
- I was literally like, I think we won,
but it's cool, its fine.
It's not a competition.
- [Kelly] No, not at all.
No, it was, it was fun
though. I loved show choir.
I had so much fun!
- I loved it. It was like,
it was the best thing that ever happened.
'cause it helped me
transition into acting.
- Yeah.
- Because show choir
is really like, you're
singing all these different
tunes and you do have to act
and dance and like,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We were, we were legit. Like
- [Kelly] It got me into
musical theater as well.
- Yeah. Well, yeah. I, I, yeah, for me
it was a different course.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like I kind of was thrust
into musical theater.
Like when I did Book of
Mormon, it was kind of like, oh
I'm doing Book of Mormon now.
I guess I'm a musical theater guy,
but I always have a (indistinct)
- That's So funny, You're so great.
- Thank you!
- Yeah. Wait, I love
that you're just like,
I guess I'll do this and
you're amazing at it.
- It does sound
- Like
- No, And this is also
the 11 year anniversary
for The Book of Mormon.
- Oh my God, it's such a great show!
- That's crazy.
- That was like one of those shows,
I feel like that one and Wicked.
I, I saw so many times
cause I kept bringing people to watch it.
- Really?
- Yes.
- Which are your favorite musicals?
Which one is like,
- Oh, like of all time?
- All time.
- Oh, that's actually
like a movie musical.
I never saw it on Broadway,
but it was Funny Girl.
I like, I yeah.
- Oh funny girl! I mean that's a classic.
- I know. I just loved that
she was her personality.
- What if you do a reboot of Funny Girl.
- They are doing a reboot of Funny Girl!
- And it's not you?
- No, because, um, I
have a lot of jobs, one.
- Okay. Right, like you are always busy.
- Yeah. They are doing it and
it's, um, Beanie. Isn't it?
- Beanie Feldstein, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
So it's gonna be, it's gonna be great.
So I'm, I'm excited about it.
I love that one. What's your favorite?
- What's it?
- Uh, I don't know if it's
because, but Carmen Jones is one
of mine, they like with
Dorothy Dandridge like
- [Kelly] I don't know that one.
- Oh my God. Carmen
Jones is like a classic.
Dorothy Dandridge and the
classic red red rose in her hair
and the like, oh my
God. And Harry Belafonte
- No! I've never seen it!
- Come on Kelly.
- I feel like I've let you down right now.
- No, you haven't. You
can never let me down.
- No, I'm gonna watch that
and I'm gonna watch the video
to "Almost Doesn't Count"
this weekend. I have homework!
- Brandy's "Almost Doesn't Count"?
- I know, but I didn't
have MTV growing up.
So I didn't, I never
saw any of the videos.
- So you never got a chance to see like
all the forbidden videos?
- No. Like when I went on
TRL, like when it used to be
on like right whenever
I got in the business.
- Yes, yes.
- They'd literally be like,
tell us your favorite videos.
And I would literally, there
was literally one point I
looked over and this guy was
like changing out the trash
and I was like, Hey, what's
one of your favorite videos?
- Like tell me where you are!
- So I, I was like, I
was like, I didn't have
- So you never got like, like
the Britney Spears videos?
Like the Destiny's Child "Say My Name"?
- I didn't see any of
that until like later,
but I still never saw that.
- Janet Jackson like videos?
- I saw like a few, like,
because like later on
like it would come across
for some reason I'd see it.
But yeah, never. I missed it
all. I just liked the music.
- So now I'm just gonna start
texting you YouTube videos.
- [Kelly] Just random videos
- Like just random like
of all the videos that
I used to love all the time.
- I know. And I'm gonna
watch musical, okay.
I've got homework.
- Okay, cool.
- Like it.
- What was your favorite album as a kid?
That's hard to do.
- You know, that's really
tricky because the very
first album I remember listening to,
my father had an extensive
vinyl collection.
Like, I mean, it was like, it
was like bookshelves of vinyl.
And so I, I was three years
old and I remember this memory
of being in a diaper and nothing else.
Um, Should I be in diapers at three?
- That's how we end as well.
- I dunno what, I dunno what,
maybe it wasn't three please don't uh
but even when I was in a diaper
and I climbed this bookshelf
and the first album I pulled out
was Michael Jackson's off the wall.
- [Kelly] Are you serious!
- And I remember I had a
Winnie the Pooh record player.
you know, remember those Winnie the Pooh
- Yep!
- Record players that were
those thick plastic uh records.
And I broke the arm off 'cause
it wouldn't reach the end
of the album. And I
like started it at, at,
in, at the beginning of this album.
And all I remember is, Ooh,
ha jigga jigga ha ha jigga...
- So of course a kid would love that!
- Oh my God. And I just was, I went crazy.
And also he had on the sparkly socks.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- So I was like, I want these swipes.
So every year I asked
for these sparkly socks
and I never got them family.
- Let me down!
- But it was my very first
album and it was unbelievable
Like I, I listened to it
from beginning to end.